[Musique]
bonjour depuis le 16 juin les députés de
la commission d' enquête consacrée à
l'épidémie de kobe 19 auditionnent les
acteurs de la crise sanitaire monde
médical mais aussi ancien ministre et
directeur généraux de la santé tout
l'été lcp vous fait revivre ces
auditions aujourd'hui celle de benoît
wallemme médecin réanimateur au chu de
lille directeur général de la santé de
2013 à 2018 auprès des ministres marisol
touraine et agnès buzyn il a longuement
été interrogé sur la gestion du stock
stratégique de masque on écoute tout de
suite
monsieur professeur mes chers collègues
nous avons entendu mardi dernier le
directeur général de la santé jérôme
salomon que nous avons questionné sur
l'organisation de la réponse à la crise
sanitaire que nous traversons et
notamment sur l'activation des
dispositifs de crise sur
l'approvisionnement en masques des
personnels de santé des résidents en
établissement et du public
les stratégies de dépistage et la
disponibilité des tests
la mobilisation du système de soins
publics et privés tout ceci renvoie
finalement à la question de l'état de
préparation dans lequel nous nous
trouvions au moment où de manière
soudaine et violente
l'épidémie de kobe de 19 est arrivé en
europe et en france
c'est pourquoi nous avons voulu
également remonter dans le temps afin
d'apprécier la manière dont cette
situation s'est constitué les raisons
qui ont conduit à la création de santé
publique france et les enseignements
tirés des précédentes épidémies
monsieur val et je vous remercie d'avoir
répondu à notre sollicitation vous êtes
docteur en médecine et praticiens
hospitaliers
vous avez été directeur général de la
santé entre octobre 2013 et janvier 2018
c'est à dire que vous êtes le
prédécesseur de monsieur salomon est
l'un des acteurs de la création de santé
publique france plus récemment vous avez
été conseiller santé auprès de jean
castex coordonnateur de la stratégie
nationale de déconfinement avant de vous
donner la parole je vais vous demander
de prêter serment
en effet l'article 6 de l'ordonance du
17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires impose aux personnes
auditionnées par une commission denquête
de prêter serment de dire la vérité
toute la vérité et rien que la vérité
je vous invite donc à lever la main
droite est à dire je le jure je le jure
je vous remercie monsieur je rappelle
que donc cette audition et public
qu'elle est diffusée en direct puis
consultables en vidéo et elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu écrit qui sera
publié monsieur je vous passez la parole
pour un propos liminaire qui précédera
notre échange de questions-réponses
vous avez la parole en sion merci madame
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames messieurs les parlementaires
votre commission m'a sollicité au titre
de mes responsabilités d'ancien
directeur général de la santé occupé du
23 octobre 2013 au 8 janvier 2018
c'est aussi en tant que médecin
professeur d'anesthésie-réanimation et
ancien président de la commission
médicale d'établissement du chu de lille
où j'ai exercé ma discipline jusqu'à ma
nomination au ministère des affaires
sociales et de la santé et du droit des
femmes que je me présente à vous la
crise qu vide a touché durement notre
pays et donc mes premières pensées cet
après midi vont d'abord vers les
personnes et les familles qui ont été
atteintes par le virus à roscoff deux
est concerné par la maladie dans la
souffrance ou le deuil
c'est dans ce contexte de crise qu vite
que dès le 16 mars en tant qu
anesthésistes réanimateurs j'ai proposé
mon engagement au directeur général de
l'assistance publique martin hirsch
lequel m'a sollicité pour observer la
réponse du grand est de la france à
cette situation sanitaire exceptionnel
et ce afin d'aider à préparer au mieux
les établissements de paris et de
l'ile-de-france
après mise à disposition de la cour des
comptes où j'exerce actuellement mes
responsabilités j'ai pu rencontrer les
19 et 20 mars les équipes de l' agence
régionale de santé et celle des services
de médecine d'urgence d'unités qu'ovide
et de réanimation des hôpitaux de
strasbourg colmar et mulhouse
je veux ici les remercier tout
particulièrement pour l'accueil qu'ils
m'ont réservé et l'aide qu'elles m'ont
apporté dans l'exercice de cette mission
vous l'avez dit madame la présidente
dans ce contexte de crise sanitaire
ma mise à disposition s'est ensuite
prolongée du 10 avril au 2 juin aux
côtés de jean castex délégué
interministériel en charge la mission de
coordination pour la stratégie nationale
du déconfinement pendant la période qui
vient de s'écouler
l'action en situation de crise et
d'après crise est ainsi redevenu mon
quotidien comme cela l'avait été aux
côtés de près de 300 agents de la
direction générale de la santé et de ses
agents sanitaires pour la préparation du
système de santé aux enjeux de situation
sanitaire exceptionnel ensemble de la
fin 2013 au début de l'année 2018
nous avons vécu auprès d'eux mêmes
touraine des épidémies de maladies
infectieuses émergentes chikungunya et
fièvre hémorragique ebola en 2014 ica en
2016 des événements saisonniers grippe d
hiver 2014 2016 vague de chaleur chaque
année d attaque terroriste massive avec
afflux de victimes et 7 janvier 2015 13
novembre 2015
14 juillet 2016 avec madame agnès buzyn
les cyclones irma et maria sur les sites
du nord des antilles en octobre 2017 où
j'ai pu me rendre sur place pendant dix
jours
cette expérience de situation sanitaire
exceptionnelle a nourri les textes de
lois de ces deux ministres et le projet
stratégique de la direction générale de
la santé présentée en octobre 2016 à
l'occasion des 60 ans de la direction
dont un des trois ans je prévoyais
d'améliorer toujours plus la gestion des
risques sanitaires environnementaux et
alimentaires dont des points spécifiques
par exemple était la nécessité de
renforcer les capacités diagnostic des
laboratoires en cas d'épidémie
la mise en place d'un mandat sanitaire
pour les professionnels de santé
ambulatoire
parce que l'ensemble des acteurs de
santé sont chaque fois en première ligne
la loi de modernisation de notre système
de santé de madame touraine de 2016 a
consacré le dispositif de préparation et
de réponse aux situations de crise dit
horse and lancé ceci dès mai 2014
avant la crise et bull a piloté par les
agences régionales de santé
son objectif a été de favoriser une
meilleure coordination régionale des
dispositifs existants dans les trois
secteurs sanitaires ambulatoire
hospitalier médico social les praticiens
libéraux ou salariés constituant le
premier maillon du parcours de santé des
patients hors
après vu leur association à la
préparation de la réponse aux situations
sanitaires exceptionnel un effort tout
particulier a été porté à l'époque avec
horse and pour la préparation aux
risques d'attentats notamment avec la
prévision de l'euro 2016 la nouvelle
agence nationale de santé publique qui
santé publique france dont je ne vais
pas détailler ici l'émission est un
autre dispositif qui a été créée par la
loi de santé et en 2015 le rapport de
lattre indiqué que ce projet de
regroupement de l'eprus avec l'hymne
veselin ps au sein de la future agence
nationale de santé publique était
pertinent le rapport insistait
d'ailleurs sur les efforts de
rationalisation qui a été fait
antérieurement par l'eprus sur le site
de vitry-le-françois
je veux insister un peu sur cette
plateforme de vitry-le-françois on y
reviendra très certainement dans les
questions d'abord au type de l'eprus
puis de santé publique france puisqu'en
fait cette plateforme s'est constitué au
fur et à mesure du temps et ça a été une
réalisation très forte de la logique de
préparation aux situations sanitaires
exceptionnelle entre 2014 et 2016 que
permettait cette plateforme de
concentrer la majeure partie du stock
stratégique d'état sur un site
centralisé en garantissant les bonnes
conditions de stockage des produits
amplitudes de températures comprises
entre 15 et 25 degrés et hygrométrie
contrôle est inhérente à chaque
référence pour la partie spécifique des
masques
la température ne devait jamais
descendre en dessous de 10 degrés donc
il y avait une garantie de chaleur
faciliter les opérations de
fiabilisation des stocks et en
particulier faire des inventaires
faciliter les études menées en
collaboration avec la nes m sur
l'extension des durées de péremption de
certains produits antibiotiques vitry
est fait de deux parties une partie
d'établissement pharmaceutique et une
partie de stocks qui sont d'ailleurs les
masques mais aussi les équipements
d'injection de vaccins des tice et pour
faire un certain nombre de choses en
matière de soins cette plateforme
permettait aussi de disposer en propre
d'une implantation incluse dans ainsi
disposant d'un haut niveau de
sécurisation puisque c'est un point
d'origine d'importance vitale
ça permettait de réduire les coûts de
stockage et la collaboration avec le
système 202,6 le service de santé des
armées
hélas l'autorisation finalement d'une
réactivité en cas de crise pour
permettre à partir de ces zones de
stockage la distribution des produits et
dès le mois d'août 2013 d'une circulaire
avait été faite sur les conditions de
distribution de ses produits avant même
d'ailleurs que cette plateforme soit
terminé j'y reviendrai dans les
questions je pense pour terminer la loi
de modernisation du système de santé a
aussi conférer une base légale au comité
d'animation du système d' agences dont
la mission est de renforcer la cohérence
et l'efficience des activités des
agences en assurant la coordination de
leur programme de travail annuel et en
élaborant des stratégies communes avec
une spécificité d'un casa décliner
comité d'animation un système d' agences
en sécurité sanitaire qui va au delà des
réunions de sécurité sanitaire du
mercredi matin auxquelles monsieur
salomon a fait référence dans son
intervention
enfin cette loi à finaliser le chantier
de réforme des vigilance sanitaire avec
vous le savez un portail qui était
ouvert la première fois en mars 2017
sur un plan plus européen pendant la
période 2013-2017 la direction générale
de la santé a activement contribué pour
le ministère et la france à
l'élaboration et la mise en oeuvre de la
décision européenne relative aux menaces
transfrontalières grave de la santé et
elle a ratifié un accord cadre qui
permet l'acquisition groupe et de
contre-mesures médicale à l'échelle
européenne et en particulier le fait de
pouvoir réserver des vaccins contre les
périodes de pandémie grippale qui permet
effectivement d'avoir une action de
niveau européen et pas simplement une
action de niveau national voilà je
voulais juste faire cette introduction
sur un certain nombre évidemment ceci
n'est pas exhaustif de mesures qui ont
été prises non seulement dans le
contexte de la loi mais parfois au delà
même de la loi pour préparer le système
de santé je suis bien sûr à votre écoute
pour répondre à vos questions
une seule rapporteur je vais vous passez
la parole
il ya merci merci beaucoup monsieur
monsieur vallée de nous consacrer ce
temps je voudrais ce stade je pense
qu'on aura plusieurs questions à la fois
sur la stratégie sanitaire qui qui a été
mise en oeuvre au cours et qui a évolué
au cours des dernières années
à partir du moment vous avez occupé de
2013 à 2018 ses responsabilités je
voudrais d'abord vous interroger sur la
problématique des masques
puisque vous avez été cité dans
l'article du 3 mai de 2020 de gérard
davet et fabrice lhomme dans le monde
de façon assez précise donc je voudrais
d'abord vous demandez un état des lieux
comme vous êtes arrivé combien il y
avait de masques combien il y en
avait-il lorsque vous avez quitter vos
fonctions vous interrogé également sur
l'état du stock de masques je crois que
c'est vous qui avez commandé les
expertises qui avait demandé une
expertise en tout cas du stock de
masques elle a été faite par santé
publique france et les conclusions sont
arrivés septembre 2001 en 2018 lierre
monsieur bourdillon le directeur général
santé publique france à l'époque nous
nous l'a indiqué le monde fait état de
votre appréciation sur sur stock de
masques en disant que selon vous je cite
de mémoire partie de ces masques aurait
pu être et aurait dû même être utilisé
et que rien de formel ne l'interdisait
donc
on a quand même eu cette expertise
qu'est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
ensuite je voudrais savoir vous avez été
nommé en octobre 2013
le secrétariat général à la défense et
la sécurité nationales définies en mai
2013 une nouvelle stratégie qui confie
chaque employeur le soin de déterminer
l'opportunité de constituer des stocks
tactique notamment de masques ffp2 pour
protéger son personnel
c'est cela nous a été dit et on le sait
changement c'est important de doctrine
comment vous avez accompagner ce
changement de doctrine et notamment
comment puisque c'est aussi un point qui
est soulevée dans l'article du monde et
que vous en tout cas je suis pas si la
situation exacte mais le monde vous fait
dire que ce qui était important c'était
de votre obsession et elle fait d'avoir
un milliard de masques et d'évaluer
comment
ce stop ses stocks tactique c'est
réserve tactique qui était notamment
dont on dispose et notamment les
établissements hospitaliers donc devait
disposer les établissements hospitaliers
étaient définis au plan local et étaient
contrôlées donc qui sur la base de cette
nouvelle doctrine a défini un nombre les
ars vous la dgs les ars centre
hospitalier de régionaux qui définit le
nombre de masques ffp2 ce que c'est une
définition purement interne qui la
contrôle donc cette question du lien
entre qu'on a évoqué ce matin d'ailleurs
avec le président du conseil
scientifique sur les outils et sur les
problématiques de gouvernance
est-ce que là vous pourrez n'était pas
une difficulté puisque auparavant il y
avait une stratégie nationale elle
subsiste en partie mais pour une autre
partie elle est déléguée à des
opérateurs plus proche du terrain mais
néanmoins ce qu'il y a une forme de
contrôle d'évaluation donc voilà à ce
stade quelques questions sur cet enjeu
essentiel des masques puisque là aussi
et au début de nos travaux nous
mesurerons et la presse l'a fait avant
nous le déficit de dans notre pays a
connus en matière de protection que ce
soit pour ses soignants dans le secteur
public dans le secteur privé que ce soit
pour les professionnels de la santé en
libéral où que ce soit tout simplement
pour la population si je peux me
permettre j'ajouterai juste une toute
petite question c'est comment sont
dimensionnés ses stocks par
établissement est ce qu'il ya une marge
de manoeuvre possible pour les
établissements où est ce que c'est
vraiment relatives à leur seul
fonctionnement
merci monsieur le rapporteur du sénat
mme la présidente
on était beaucoup de questions
immédiatement qui montre votre
connaissance du sujet alors je vais
essayer de les de les prendre une à une
pour essayer d'expliquer au maximum le
rationnel de tous ces sujets pour ce qui
est du nombre
et donc ce nombre est a été maintenant
souvent indiqué d'ailleurs le rapport
delà de la commission que vous m que
vous avez animé madame préalablement à à
montrer effectivement ces chiffres quand
je suis arrivé fin 2013 les stocks
disposait de 616 millions de masques
adultes et 213 millions de masques
pédiatrique
il y avait également des ffp2 qui était
en 2012 et je retrouverai tout à l'heure
le chiffre pour la période de sud
arrivent et qui était en 2012 de 480
millions et sur la période de haut
je suis arrivé je vous lundi craie après
un anglais voici il était
à 380 millions donc les ffp2 avait à ce
moment là une existence dans ses stocks
stratégiques d'état la période où je
suis là je fais rentrer une quantité de
masques qui monte à 100 millions de
masques chirurgicaux adultes
ce qui m'amène à terminer ma période
c'est-à-dire en 2017
avec un chiffre de 714 millions de
masques comme vous savez compter 616
plus ans devra est égal à 7 116 et donc
il ya deux millions de masques qui ont
été à ce moment-là éliminés parce qu'ils
avaient été considérés comme non
utilisables et donc c'était un travail
qui a été fait de façon récurrente
d'inventaire de façon relativement macro
de la qualité de ces masses c'est dire
qu'on ne rentrait pas dans une analyse
on reviendra bien sûr là dessus après on
ne rentrait pas dans une analyse qui
était forcément détaillé démarche menée
par exemple des boîtes
des éléments de conteneurs qui avait
souffert et ceci témoigne de ces deux
millions qu'ont disparu en sachant que
ceci n'est pas forcément sur vitry
puisqu'en réalité ça va beaucoup été dit
mais le stock stratégique de l'état il
est à vitry le françois mais il est
aussi sur les zones de défense et il est
aussi en outre mer donc en fait il est
réparti sur plusieurs sites les
d'ailleurs ceci a été une simplification
d'une situation antérieure où le nombre
de sites contenant des masques du stock
stratégique était de 73 donc ça c'est
avant 2010 c'est au début de la
structuration du dispositif est donc une
partie de la logique à partir de 2010
les années qui ont suivi a été de
rapprocher il ya d'abord eu cette
plateforme nationale puis
progressivement de concentrer ya eu un
effort de concentration de ce stock qui
est important à bien comprendre mais
avec des dispositifs zonaux qui sont
restés et des dispositifs aux outre-mer
pour une logique de proximité d'action
dans toute cette période là notre
appréciation et que ce stock de masques
est en état d'utilisation puisque c'est
616 millions dont je parle sont sans
péremption en revanche les sens qu'on
achète ont pris une date de péremption
puisqu'en réalité à partir de 2010 les
industriels ont considéré qu'il était
compliqué d'avoir des dispositifs
médicaux puisque les masques
chirurgicaux adultes ou pédiatriques
on viendra soit ffp2 après puisque ces
masques sont des dispositifs médicaux
ils ont considéré que c'est difficile de
garantir qu'ils soient son père option
mais en tout état de cause ce qui
garantit ceux qui étaient à l'intérieur
du stock stratégique était considérée
sans péremption sauf les sons qu'on
avait acquis et donc dont la péremption
apparaissent m
pourquoi est ce que les stocks de
masques chirurgicaux sont considérés
sont péremption parce qu'ils ne se
dégradent pas la différence et ffp2 dont
les modules hydrostatique qui permettent
la lutte contre les gouttelettes contre
les vapes les aérosols pardon
nécessite effectivement cette capacité
électrostatique qui se dégrade en une
perte de 3 4 ou 5 ans ça a été un des
éléments forts pour dire qu'on ne
pouvait pas les stocker puisqu'ils
allaient se dégrader la date de
péremption que les industriels ont
ajouté après pose de fait la même
question donc ça c'est une question pour
pour le présent et le futur
mais en tout état de cause ces masques
étaient considérés comme non non
périssables et donc ils nous donnaient
je dirais beaucoup de sécurité en termes
de d'utilisation pourquoi est ce que les
choses changent pas tellement parce que
les industriels ont une date de
péremption mais plutôt parce qu'en 2014
apparaît une nouvelle norme et cette
norme ajoute à ce qu'ils sont les
qualités de filtres habilité et de
résistance vous avez la filtration qui
est considéré comme une frustration
bactérienne puisque ce sont des outils
d'abord anti projections pour ce qui est
des masques chirurgicaux dont vous avez
la capacité de filtration et la
résistance à la ventilation si vous
préférez on sait par exemple que les
masques tisser sont plus résistants que
le sont les masques chirurgicaux sont
plus confortables
voilà ça vient de cette capacité de
pression qui peut y avoir à déclencher
pour faire passer leur est donc une
troisième normes et apparaît en 2014 un
troisième critère qui hélas n'ont cas de
contamination bactérienne et donc on
considère qu'il doit y avoir une
quantité donnée de présence bactérienne
sur les masses pour qu'il puisse être
utilisé ou non ce ne sont pas des outils
stérile c'est à dire qu'ils sont
naturellement contaminés après la
quantité de contamination peut et c'est
logique devenir un problème quand on
parle de contamination on parle là de
2,2 quantité extrêmement faible
un son en colonie formant unités ce qui
est une unité de bactériologie et donc
2014 cette nouvelle norme apparaissant
la logique à un moment donné se voulait
qu'il puisse y avoir une réévaluation de
ce stock de masques
vous verrez que ça nous amène à la
question de l'évaluation qui ont été
faites en 2020 or ceci est enregistré à
la fin de l'année 2014 et je sollicite
l' agence du médicament pour demander
comment évaluer les masques
pour savoir quelle est leur caractère
opérables et l' agence du médicament m'a
répondu en indiquant qu'il y avait deux
laboratoires qui était capable de faire
l'ensemble de ces critères dont un
laboratoire nord américain qui s'appelle
nelson est un laboratoire belge qui
s'appelle sentex belle qui est devenu
maintenant un laboratoire célèbre et
donc les discussions débutent dès en
2015 pour et je vous vois des demandes
auprès de l'eprus de son directeur pour
savoir comment procéder en terme d'appel
d'offres de plan d'échantillonnage et
bref comment on commence à faire une
évaluation et comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure c'est le moment où les
mouvements de concentration du stock
stratégique se font et ils vont se
dérouler toute l'année 2015 et une
partie de l'année 2016 plus de 1000
camions qui vont transporter des
palettes pour les faire venir sur le
stock central nous étions à ce moment là
avec cette plateforme nationale qui
constitueront une plateforme centrale
qui est vitry avec cette idée donc j'ai
indiqué dans mon les propos liminaires
d'un endroit sécurisé d'un endroit
contrôlé sur le plan climatique
température hygrométrie et c'est
sécurisé aussi dans son anneau
n'identifie qu'à sion est justement avec
un endroit où ayant tous enfin plus
grande partie du stock la possibilité de
faire un inventaire récurrent est de
faire une évaluation qui aurait été une
évaluation sur une sur les éléments
d'échantillonnage
non ça c'est ça cette période de
mouvements
cette noria de dispositifs qui ramène
l'essentiel à vitry sept toute l'année
2015 et une partie de l'année 2016 et
donc nous n'avons pas ces échanges
auront sans doute à prolonger avec le
directeur de l'eprus mais nous n'avons
pas décidé à ce moment là de cet
échantillonnage pour la raison suivante
c'est que quand vous faites
un appel d'offres est que vous devez
déclenché cet appel d'offres est utilisé
les moyens pour aller au terme de
l'objet de cet appel d'offres il est en
durée limitée et donc nous étions sur
une période de plus d'un nom de
mouvement et donc il semblait
raisonnable d'avoir attendu la mise en
place du stock central pour faire une
évaluation corps était une évaluation
large avec un plan d'échantillonnage
large etc
alors vous direz vous auriez pu le faire
avant les déplacements sauf que si vous
transportez des masques et que vous les
habits mais en cours de route parce
qu'en fait il ya des cartons qui ont été
abîmés en cours de route
certains qui ont été écartés dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure
et bien vous allez annulé finalement
l'échantillonnage que vous aurez fait
avant et donc il était raisonnable
d'attendre d'avoir constitué le stock
central et de l'analyser et de pouvoir
faire un inventaire correct et donc
c'est comme ça qu'en 2016 fin 2016 les
réunions conduisent à la saisine que
j'ai envoyée en avril 2017 pour avoir
une idée de ce stock puisque
effectivement nous arrivions au delà de
10 ans pour un certain nombre de ces
produits et qui semblait tout à fait
raisonnable de les évaluer
il faut que vous représentiez ski et
vitry on a vu peu de photos d'ailleurs
mais c'est un endroit qui est rassurant
je dire ce n'est pas un dépôt de
deuxième de deuxième ordre c'est d'abord
un dépôt où il ya un établissement
pharmaceutique qui a été validé par l'
agence du médicament en 2015 comme en
répondant aux bonnes pratiques
pharmaceutiques et il y à la partie
d'entrepôts qui correspond aux masques
comme je dis tout à l'heure à des
dispositifs de vaccination des
dispositifs permettant de faire un
certain nombre de soins etc et donc tout
ceci est dans un site qui est
extrêmement sérieux et il y à un
pharmacien en permanence sur place deux
jours par semaine donc une présence
physique et un inventaire ou un examen
de la situation de stockage qui ferait
que si une partie cet établissement se
trouve est abîmée
ce qui est en dessous serait
immédiatement analysé ou écartés et si
vous avez vu les photos et je pense est
important vous en ayez dans votre
dossier je pourrais vous en faire passer
si vous le souhaitez c'est très
rassurant
venons en maintenant à l'analyse de son
ex-belle donc cette analyse de sang
texte belle est là elle a reporté sur
quelques références en fait ça a été
expliqué par monsieur bourdillon hier
alors je veux dire ici que moi je n'ai
pas eu le retour de cette analyse
puisque je suis parti en réalité
quasiment à la fin 2010 est parti lui
janvier 2018
et donc ce retour est venue en septembre
octobre 2018 donc je n'ai jamais vu le
retour de l'analyse mais elle a été
présentée dans le journal libération et
il a il a été dit que cette analyse
avait été fait sur quatre est interdit
par monsieur bourdilhan hier quatre des
12 références qu'il y avait dans ses
stocks et donc chaque pour comprendre ce
que sont ses références chaque chacun
des producteurs dont un certain nombre
de producteurs français se voyait
commandes et des stocks
et il y avait par l'eau ou par un
producteur ou par référence un nombre de
masques données et donc sans texte belle
a choisi de faire l'analyse de quatre
références parmi les plus gros volumes
est ce que dit le journal c'est que il y
a eu 80% de l'analyse qui correspondait
à ses références en plus grand nombre ce
que dieu c'est journal c'est que le
nombre d'échantillons et est faible
puisque je crois il était de l'ordre de
25 masques par barlow et que les
conclusions qui ont été portés sur les
quatre premières références ont arrêté
l'analyse et n'a pas été poursuivie sur
les huîtres supplémentaires c'est une
c'est une
c'est une analyse très exigeante très
exigeante sur les indicateurs que je
vous ai présenté et donc ça a été dit
aussi
hier donc sur ce résultat qui d'ailleurs
pour ce que moi j'en ai lu se présente
comme une non conformité à la norme de
2007 2014 mais des masques fabriqués en
2005-2006 peuvent pas être conforme à la
norme de 2014 c'est logique mais en tout
cas sur la foi d ce qui était demandé
ces masques sont considérés comme non
conforme et un ordre de destruction est
portée
j'ai jamais indiqué que ces masques
aurait dû être conservés pour être
utilisés j'ai jamais dit ça parce que je
n'en ai pas d'élément ce que j'ai
indiqué simplement
et ça ça a été le fait de ma présence la
commission castex et donc aux échanges
qui a eu à cette période avec des
cellules d'activité du ministère la
santé donc la cellule test la cellule
masque cellule épidémiologique une
organisation de travail que le
déconfinement à aborder c'est que quand
il s'est agi de trouver et de continuer
à abonder sur des masques notamment de
masques dits grand public
quelles qualités ces masques devait
avoir ils ont été ré analysés et cette
fois ci ils ont été analysés par une
analyse combinée de la direction
générale de l'armement et de l' agence
du médicament
pourquoi ce n'est pas eux qui ont été
sollicités à l'époque puisque je vous
dis que j'avais demandé à l'agent du
médicament comment procéder et bien tout
simplement parce que l' agence du
médicament faisait que la partie enfin
j'imagine que c'est l'explication
faisait que la partie contamination
bactériologique et que
les autres laboratoires ne faisait pas
cette partie là et que son ex belle
faisait l'ensemble est donc il y a eu ce
pour les raisons de savoir faire
j'imagine un choix qui s'est porté sur
d'autres d'autres partenaires toujours
est il que l'action conjuguée de la dg a
et de l'année sem a conclu sur les
références qui ont été ré analysé que
ces masses que pouvaient pouvait
répondre à des catégories nouvelles qui
étaient apparues et qui étaient les
masques grand public où les masses pour
la population générale et je vais
revenir après sur ces notions et que les
critères qui était observé les rendait
tout à fait compatibles à leur usage en
population générale
alors pour être un peu précis sur cette
question des masques et à qui elle
s'adresse et leur utilité
on pourrait concerner on pourrait
considérer trois situations la
population générale avec des personnes
malades ou non les professionnels de
santé ayant pas d acte invasif et les
productions de santé qui font des actes
invasifs nommément notamment les
anesthésistes-réanimateurs et pas les
anesthésistes-réanimateurs tout le temps
là nestea sera un moteur qui fait une
intubation s'était fait une argos copie
il est très près du patient un
estimateur qui fait une aspiration
bronchique un gastroentérologue qui fait
une inspiration une fibre digestive un
pneumologue une fibre bronchique et
c'est donc des situations où l'aérosol
isation existe et où la protection doit
être garanti par des masques ffp2 avec
une capacité d'euros statique autrement
dit ce que le haut conseil de santé
publique avait précisé en 2011
c'était 7
attribution des masques en fonction des
catégories et donc en limitant les ffp2
et on reviendra après sur la ffp de en
limitant les ffp2 à ces catégories là ce
qui n'était pas le cas antérieurement
c'est à dire que la constitution des
stocks stratégiques
à l'époque du délégué interministériel
pour la lutte contre la grippe aviaire
monsieur 800 il y avait pas cette
différenciation entre des masques ffp2
pour des soignants très particulier et
les masques chirurgicaux le le masque
ffp2 était pour les processeurs de santé
ce qui fait qu'il ya eu d'ailleurs une
association oui c'est ça il ya une heure
avant avant d'en avant 2011 même je
reviens à 2011 il ya une association
forte qui a été que le ffp2 c'est pour
tous les soignants ce qui est ce qui
n'était plus le cas avec la doctrine du
haut conseil de santé publique de 2011
qui précisait bien que le ffp2 avait des
indications précises et d'ailleurs ils
ont refait récemment il ya un nouvel
avis du 38 10 mars 2020 où ils ont
repris l'attribution des masques en
fonction des profils notamment de
soignants et donc qu'ils attribuent le
ffp2 cas cette es7 ce segment là et donc
est donc le haut-conseil 7,7
cette appréciation de l'attribution des
masques à l'époque c'est donc le
secrétaire général de la défense et de
la sûreté nationale avec les ministères
avec la représentation de l'elysée de
matignon établi une nouvelle doctrine
pour les ffp2 mais ne change pas cette
logique de stocks stratégiques d'état
par ailleurs indépendamment du ffp2
c'est à dire que la cible la cible du
milliard quelque part est non ce n'est
pas une obsession personnelle mais c'est
une cible qui reste celle qui est
revendiquée donc pour moi par rapport à
cette réévaluation de
de la dgh de la nes m la réflexion qui
peut être posée c'est qu'en population
générale
ces masques aurait trouvé un emploi par
exemple quand ils ont été recommandés
vous avez vu dans le déconfinement quand
ils ont été recommandées dans les
transports en commun en particulier
parce que si tout le monde porte un
masque
le vis-à-vis peut il est bien de
respecter les mesures de barrière
physique autant qu'il est possible mais
le vis-à-vis peut être assurée avec un
port qui importe des deux personnes
l'une en face de l'autre
et ceci est d'ailleurs d'une certaine
manière validé par le fait que deux
personnes qui se trouvent là en face de
l'autre avec un masque ne sont pas
considérés comme des cas contacts parce
que c'est une définition aussi quand on
recherche à partir d'un cas positifs 1
qu'accompagne donc l'hypothèse qu'ils
pouvaient être formulée à ce moment là
était de se dire au fond peut-être que
ces masques n'avait plus le niveau de
masques chirurgicaux adultes pour
professionnels de santé non
spécifiquement exposés à des aérosols
isation etc mais ayant besoin d'avoir
une filtre habilité succès et cetera
mais pouvait être finalement utilisé en
population générale et chez les
personnes non malades aussi c'est aussi
important et donc si vous voulez ce
point là de mon point de vue pouvait
mériter une interrogation
et il se trouve et ça c'est sans doute
un élément de confirmation de ces propos
qu' une partie de ces masques ont été
déclassés et utiliser et madame chen
annoncé 86 millions sur les 260 millions
je crois qu'elle a indiqué qu'ils
avaient été non concernés par la
destruction
j'en viens à un point qui mérite aussi
qu'on passe un peu de temps qui est
celui des stocks tactique par rapport à
des stocks stratégiques
les appellations sont pas immédiatement
parlante les stocks tactique en fait
sont des stocks d'intervention
donc ils sont faits d'un certain nombre
d'éléments qui permettent de faire face
à des victimes pendant un temps limité
24 heures et ils sont plus ou moins
importants ces stocks tactiques sont
répartis selon leur volume d' usage
entre les samu donc sur plus de 100
établissements nationaux ou au niveau
des chu donc plus d'une trentaine
lorsqu'ils sont plus conséquents donc en
fait on les appelle poste sanitaire
mobile psm de niveau 1 c'est pour 25
victimes
donc c'est plutôt limité en volume
ceux là sont au niveau des samu et puis
les ps m 2 qui sont en réalité pour 200
victimes et qui sont d'un volume
évidemment plus important plus
conséquents permettent de faire de
l'activité chirurgicale initial par
exemple et donc on les avait rénové dans
le contexte des attentats pour faire par
exemple du damage control c'est à dire
de la chirurgie interventionnelle sur le
terrain qui permet de limiter notamment
les lésions hémorragique et qui permet
de transporter les victimes vers une
une ressource sanitaires plus plus forte
et puis en 2010 est donc moi j'avais
demandé à ce que ceux ci puissent être
installés sur notamment les élèves et
les et les événements de nice j'avais
demandé à ce qu'il puisse y avoir des
psm pédiatrique pour qu'effectivement
cette notion de prise en charge de
l'enfant puisse être fait pas pour les
nouveaux nés mais au moins pour les
enfants de moins de 10 ans et donc il y
en a eu 25 qui ont été installés à
l'époque en 2017
alors est ce que ces stocks tactique
comporte ou pas d'effets fp2 voilà une
question qui est finalement logique par
rapport à tout ce qu'on se dit la
réponse est en obligations non mais les
éléments de doctrine rénové que vous
avez évoqué donc de 2011 le la vidéo
conseil et de 2013 pour ce qui est de la
doctrine du sgdsn ont été indiquées aux
agences régionales de santé donc ça
c'est mon prédécesseur qui sont nés
occupée monsieur graal et je pense qu'il
reviendra sur 7 sur cet élément là au
moins deux
je pense au mois deux mois de mars très
peu de temps après que là que là je vais
vous indiquer la date exacte
et la constitution de ses stocks de ffp2
n'a pas été précisée en volume donc il y
a eu une indication de changement de
doctrine liés je le rappelle au fait que
ces maçons fragile c'est à dire que ils
se dégradent à cause de la qualité
hydrostatique doivent présenter donc un
temps très limité 2 avec un usage
réservé à certains types de
professionnels de santé très limités et
donc sur ces éléments là une doctrine
évolutive et donc un transfert vers les
services de santé et donc cette cette
doctrine a été transféré via les agences
régionales de santé
dès novembre 2011 la gestion des
situations sanitaires exceptionnel
revenait de plus en plus aux agences
régionales de santé avec une logique
d'animation de la cartographie sanitaire
et des établissements de santé
donc toute la partie qui a été développé
dans les suites de cette nouvelle
doctrine du secrétariat général qui ne
changeaient pas la logique du milliard
pour les stocks stratégiques d'état a
donné la main aux établissements de
santé par rapport à la constitution de
ses stocks de ffp2 alors est ce que pour
autant
on en était resté là en fait non puisque
vous imaginez que la mise en place de
ces stocks tactique donc de cpsm 1 et 2
et de niveau 2 et les pédiatrique leur
usage hors utilisation par exemple dans
le cadre de la crise que vivent des
ventilateurs ont été utilisés à partir
de ces stocks tactique suppose qu'on les
suivants qu'on sache s'ils sont
regénérer si les produits qui ont été
utilisés ne sont ou non arrivée à date
de péremption il ya aussi des antidotes
il ya un certain nombre de produits
pharmaceutiques à l'intérieur ça suppose
un suivi et donc nous avons installé à
l'époque donc à partir de 2015
un système d'information qui s'appelle
le système d'information de gestion des
sinistres situation sanitaire
exceptionnel si j'ai ce qui est un 6
un système qui est renseigné sur ses
stocks tactique et sur les éléments
qu'il comporte et les différents items à
suivre et les établissements de santé
peuvent renseigner les ffp2 c'est un ce
n'est pas obligatoire mais ils peuvent
renseigner les faits fait deux pour
donner l'état de ses stocks et pour
avoir cette information
je n'ai pas eu après je sais que nous
avions maintenu le système sigf et
continue toujours d'être opérationnel il
est toujours opérationnelle aujourd'hui
nous l'avons nous l'avons maintenu à
santé publique france et ce système je
pense a été utilisé pendant la crise que
vite pour faire un recensement des
moyens au niveau national voilà je n'ai
pas eu à titre personnel de d'éléments
de réponse par rapport à son usage
voilà quelques éléments qui essayent de
de commencer de répondre aux questions
précises que vous m'avez posé sur les
stocks la qualité de ses stocks et
les éléments je vous ai laissé bien
expliquer parce que c'est extrêmement
intéressant et surtout très précis et
donc ça ne méritait pas qu'on vous
interrompre avez des questions je pense
maintenant je vais me permettre de
laisser mes collègues vous poser
quelques questions commençant par jean
christophe lagarde pour lui des jeunes
ça y est ça fonctionne c'est
effectivement très intéressant et ça
apporte des éléments qui sont nouveaux
quand on compare ce qu'on a entendu
jusqu'à présent voyez une chose quand
même c'est que voudrait bien expliquer
pourquoi en fait en 2014 une nouvelle
norme arrive sans doute à ce moment là
si miss le questionnement sur notre
stock de masse sont d'état sont
opérabilité son opérationnalité on
attend 2017 vous avez pourquoi je pense
que les choix peuvent être contestable
mais surtout ça veut dire quand même qu
entre 2014 et 2017
on a accepté assumer qu'un doute
existait sur l'état de nos masses c'est
à dire si l'épidémie qui est survenu en
2020 était survenue en 2015 et en 2016
on n'aurait sans doute pas été capable
de dire aux décideurs publics
ces maçons utilisable ou pas la deuxième
chose c'est sur la date de péremption
que vous avez affirmé en 2010 des
fabricants disent finalement les
produits que nous livrerons désormais
elles ont une date de péremption
vous nous avez expliqué pourquoi il me
semble que ça devait conduire à deux
questions et si non pourquoi
la première c'est bah du coup s'il ya
une belle option pour ceux qui sont
fabriqués en 2010 on peut se demander si
elle pas une péremption pour ceux qui
sont en 2004 2005 et ça on doit se poser
la question de 2010 mais je veux votre
sentiment c'est que vous n'étiez pas en
responsabilité et la deuxième c'est dans
vos propos j'ai pas eu le sentiment
finalement que le ministère de la santé
ait son mot à dire sur la date de
péremption décrété par les fabricants de
vérification de ça ce qui pourrait
laisser penser d'une certaine façon une
obsolescence programmée un peu cynique
non contrôlé parce qu'on a vu que des
masques et qui sont théoriquement
périmés garde en fait une bonne partie
je parle de l'efs espère là pour le
compte plus que ffp2 garde une bonne
partie de leur propriété et donc de leur
réussite et partant de là il ya une
chose que je ne comprends pas depuis le
début on nous a expliqué qu'il ya à peu
près de 100 millions de masques 200 250
millions de masques qu'ils sont
consommés par les établissements de
santé en france s'établit en public ça
que chaque année et puis finalement en
2010 semble indiquer une péremption de
cinq ans et on a un objectif d'un
milliard je fais une division peut-être
stupide mais un milliard / 5 ça fait 200
millions et on se demande pourquoi
peut-être qu'ils gagnent donc très
bonnes raisons à ça plutôt que de dire
aux hôpitaux acheter vos masques on
vient pas chaque année prendre 200
millions de masques 250 millions de
masse dans un stock stratégique corps
constitués qui comme ça et tout le temps
opérationnel pourquoi finalement cette
mécanique s'est pas mise en place un
j'ai été maire leur a porté au président
d'un conseil départemental c'est le
genre de choses qu'on aurait fait assez
naturellement chez nous d'ailleurs
accessoirement moi c'est ce que j'ai
fait quand j'ai vu qu'il y avait une
nouvelle règle pour acheter des masques
sur le dernier point enfin vraiment vers
des points ya normalement quand il ya
changement de doctrine qui dit on donne
aux administrations aux hôpitaux etc
la responsabilité à l'employeur la
responsabilité de constituer un mas
normalement les ars doivent le contrôle
et doivent le vérifier légalement
parlant cette période de transition
c'est exactement celle où vous êtes
directeur général de la santé entre 2013
de les visionner 18 avez vous donné des
instructions aux ars pour qu'ils aillent
contrôler ses stocks
les stops dans les entreprises dans les
hôpitaux dans les administrations avez
vous eu des rapports avec les préfets
des sept zones de défense qui avait pour
mission théoriquement eux aussi une fois
par an de vérifier que nous avions bien
ceci ici ça n'a pas été fait ou si vous
n'avez pas été entendu ou si les arrêts
sont pas pensé pourquoi
enfin il ya quand même quelque chose qui
me turlupine depuis hier l'ancien
directeur général
santé publique france que nous avons
entendu qui a géré la fusion nous a
quand même dit il avait dit la presse
mais que finalement il ya un sujet c'est
que la doctrine du secrétaire du
secrétariat général de la défense
nationale disait en cas d'épidémie les
masses sont utiles c'est pas la seule
chose utile mais c'est utile donc sont
nécessaires d'où vous avez vous
l'objectif de monter au milliard de
masques mais qu'au fond à la tête du
ministère de la santé est sans doute pas
les dirigeants d'aujourd'hui seulement
des gens doutaient de l'utilisation du
masque on a l'impression d'une
dichotomie à la tête de l'état peut-être
vous étiez vous avez travaillé avec
madame touraine d'autres on les entendra
travail avec les ministres lui ont
succédé
peut-être précédé on a l'impression que
finalement on a une doctrine secrétariat
général de la défense nationale et que
ministère de la santé ne la partage pas
est-ce que vous pensez que ça a joué un
rôle dans la décision la non décision de
renouveler le stock de masse puisque on
a bien vu hier que finalement on
découvre il ya des masques qu'ils sont
théoriquement pas opérationnel on les
bazarde et on rachète pas la quantité de
masques correspondante et avez vous eu
l'occasion d'échanger avec jean raoul
salomon lorsqu'il était au cabinet de
madame torrent sur ce sujet là j'imagine
qu'il y avait un débat au sein du
ministère de la santé sur ok on nous
demande de faire ça mais est ce que
c'est bien utile voilà pardon madame le
président que j'ai été long mais
j'essaie d'être cohérent
comme on est moins nombreux jeux je suis
plus huppés remuage voyez vous allez je
vous laisse répondre
alors tout d'abord préciser donc l'envoi
de l'information sur la nouvelle
doctrine âgées des scènes aux agences
régionales de santé et le fait qu'elle
prenne effectivement la main pour les
établissements sur l'effet p2 est envoyé
en juin 2013 donc assez logiquement
juste après
la publication en mai de 7 cette
doctrine
oui donc alors encore une fois là le
suivi des ffp2 revenait aux
établissements là le monitorage de ceux
de ce niveau 2 2 d'organisation pour
constituer pour chaque établissement d
ffp2 n'a pas démarrer tout de suite et
il a fallu comme je l'aï indiqué
précédemment mettre en place un système
d'information dont en 2017 90 87 %
environ du système étaient déployées ça
veut dire qu' il allait verser ces
établissements de santé qui participait
à cette constitution de stocks et les
établissements leur enseigner mais
encore une fois sans aucun caractère
d'obligation ceux ci aient été instruits
par les agences régionales mais sans
aucun caractère d'obligation du point de
vue du ministère pour des ffp2 encore
une fois dont je rappelle que c'était
ciblé sur des populations de médecins
extrêmement spécifique
et pour lesquelles les établissements
avaient je dirais le volume d'acteurs
potentiels en période qu'elle soit une
période dite de paix ou une période de
situation pandémique
donc ce volume peut être extrêmement
différent d'un établissement à l'autre
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'investisseur et
animateurs pascal pas forcément de
pneumologues sont la fibroscopie que
sèche donc c'est quelque chose qui est
quand même très variable d'un site à
l'autre et donc s'être ce recensement de
l'information s'est fait de manière de
plus d'une façon de plus en plus
automatisés ont par tuer sur les psm 1
et l'épaisse m2 au cours du temps grâce
à ce système d'information je veux dire
ici aussi que nous avons monté dans
toute cette période je l'ait pas dit
mais énormément d'amélioration du
système d'information le système
d'information des alertes et crise qui
est permet aux chorus donc et le centre
opérationnel de régulation et de réponse
aux urgences sanitaires du ministère
le recueil de l'ensemble des alertes qui
peut intervenir sur territoire la mise
en place du portail de vigilance
sanitaire est aussi pour les agences
régionales de santé le système
d'information veille et sécurité
sanitaire que nous avons pendant la
période où j'étais là interconnectés
pour que les agences puissent haussier
récupérer le détail de ces alertes
sanitaires nationales ou régionales
et puis il y a eu récemment vous le
savez le système d'information pour les
prélèvements biologiques dans le cadre
du testing donc si depp et le système
d'information civique qui a suivi les
attentats en réalité qu'on a aussi mis
en place dans la période 2016 2017 qui
permet le recensement des présences à
l'hôpital et donc tout là tout le suivi
de la crise sur les données de présence
hospitalière
a été fait par civique et toute la
partie qui concerne les passages les
passages aux urgences par le système qui
s'appelle au secours et donc qui permet
de recenser les passages aux urgences
qui était un système d' alerte très
précoce dans le suivi de cette crise
sanitaire et qui a été avant que le test
développe et que le rationnel de suivi
des tests soit par cidep soient
opérationnels complètement qui a été
utilisé comme un signal d'alerté précoce
et de reprise éventuelle du dispostif
donc une très grosse structure de
système d'information permettant de
recueillir toutes ces informations sur
le déploiement des stocks tactique et
donc de leur suivi
donc ce système n'existait pas et s'est
progressivement développée avec la
capacité de faire de recensement de plus
en plus important avec comme je l'aï dit
au début cette idée que depuis 2000 11
novembre 2011 des agences régionales de
santé sont devenus les acteurs
principaux
vis-à-vis des établissements de santé
public privé et aussi des professionnels
libéraux comme comme je les dis aussi
dans mes propos liminaire l'articulation
avec les préfets est prévue par orson
donc horse and c'est le premier les
premières informations à destination des
agences régionales de santé en lien avec
les préfets c'est mai 2014
et ça a été précédée comme message
d'instruction sur les stockage et la
distribution par une circulaire d'août
2013 signé par monsieur valls qui était
à l'époque mise de l'intérieur et madame
touraine qu'était mise et la santé sur
cette organisation a déployé sur le
terrain donc un système qui est très
élaborée et qui est d'une certaine façon
déconcentrés et dont la responsabilité
revient maintenant aux agences
régionales de santé vous posiez la
question de l'efficacité des masques
s'il vous plaît monsieur lagarde y ait
encore des gens qui ont des questions
donc n'établissait pas un dialogue m
le contrôle est sous la responsabilité
des agences régionales de santé
c'est elle qui ont la responsabilité de
cette organisation et pour ce qui est du
du ministère c'est le recueil d'une
information déconcentrés et qui est en
permanence sollicités dans des moments
où on souhaite avoir un état des lieux
on n'a pas forcément besoin d'un état
des lieux en toute circonstance vous
avez posé la question de l'efficacité
des masques savoir si c'est un débat au
ministère la santé non c'est pas un
débat au mystère la santé les masques
ont d efficacité qui sont d'autant plus
grande que le l'agent pathogène
respiratoire est contagieux et dans le
cas particulier de vide il s'est révélé
être présents alors même que les
personnes et est asymptomatique ce qui
en a fait une situation particulière
tout table sur le plan de la gestion de
l'épidémie
quand on prend les études qui ont
précédé les stocks
le plan pandémie grippale puis l'avis du
haut conseil
puis des études qui ont été ensuite
reprise par jean paul stahl dans son
rapport d expertise présenté en
septembre 2010 8,1 françois bourdillon
et aux directeurs de la santé puis
publié en mai 2019
il part de d'études ou l'efficacité du
masque est d'autant plus grande que le
virus est pathogène est d'origine
respiratoire sur les grippes sur la
grippe saisonnière il y a eu de la
discussion sur des études qui étaient
randomisés ou l'évidence delà de
l'efficacité du mas ne venait pas
toujours et c'est sans doute une des
raisons pour lesquelles ce masque n'est
pas rentré dans la culture nationale
pour la grippe saisonnière comme on le
voit dans des pays asiatiques et c'est
sans doute un des objets à faire évoluer
et jérôme salomon a indiqué qu'il avait
fait cette expérimentation dans le cadre
de l'article 51 de la loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour permettre en
région nouvelle aquitaine le déploiement
très important en population générale du
masque en période de grippe hivernale de
telle sorte qu'une culture aussi
s'installe de l'usaj
du masque mais je pense pas qu on
indique qu'il faut constituer une
protection de la population à hauteur de
20 millions de personnes
avec 50 boîtes de masse par 50 masse par
boîte si on ne pense pas que cette
mesure a un intérêt et je ne pense pas
qu'on ait établi cette ses stocks
ce stock central au niveau national ces
efforts qui ont été faits de
rationalisation de son emplacement et
son utilisation
si on pense que ça n'a pas un intérêt
c'est ça a été dit par monsieur bourde
ayant fière c'est une mesure avec
d'autres et ce qu'on sait très bien de
ces gc sion maintenant d'épidémie et
écovie doha était évidemment une source
d'information gigantesque c'est qu'elles
s'additionnent chacune contribuer à
améliorer encore la baisse de la
transmission de personne à contacter est
donc cette ces éléments vont être de
plus en plus reconnu et vous avez
berkeley qui a fait une revue des pays
et de l' usage systématique systémique
du masque d'ailleurs par participant la
culture les pays asiatiques
la corée du sud singapour etc et comment
quand on regarde l'évolution du nombre
de personnes concernées par la
pathologie
l'intervention du masque a joué de façon
importante avec une diminution de moitié
de la transmission et vraisemblablement
aussi d'autres stratégies que ce soit le
repérage rapide et étendu des personnes
contacts etc
c'est pour ça qu'on peut espérer je fais
juste ce point là dans le cadre du
déconfinement c'est pour ça qu'on peut
juste espérer qu'en appliquant de
manière plus forte
ces mesures qui sont ces mesures
de 12h du masque de gel hydroalcoolique
de distance physique autant qu'il est
possible pendant une période encore
assez longue
on évitera et puis bien sûr
l'identification des personnes atteintes
et les personnes contacts c'est comme ça
qu'on évitera certainement l'obligation
d'un re confinement massif qui est
évidemment tellement préjudiciable pour
nos organisations sociales non non je
voulais juste je voulais juste indiqué
que pour la période qui a qui a séparé
2014 normes qui indiquait peut-être une
identification à nouveau de la situation
nomade qui était garanti sans péremption
et on voit que ce terme là prend
évidemment une connotation caduque à un
moment donné
toujours est il que pour nous à cette
période là ces masques sont considérées
comme sans durée de vie limitée on en
fait rentrer de nouveau dans cette
logique que vous indiquez d'un stock qui
progressivement se retournant mais on ne
va pas beaucoup plus loin à ce moment où
on recentre tous ces éléments nous ne
disposons et dont j'ai déjà fait
largement pas et qui sont très très
dispersé la question se pose est
évidemment à partir du moment où l
expertise revient et où un certain
nombre d'autres hypothèses doivent être
mises en route
vous avez indiqué le chiffre de 40
millions 40 à 50 millions de masques par
ans et c'est là c'est la chronique
habituel de chiffrer les données quand
même assez important pour les masques
chirurgicaux adultes et ils passent à la
il passe à la semaine en situation de
crise donc vous le savez les stocks sont
établies sur l'hypothèse de 12 semaines
d'une première vague séparer de cinq
semaines avec une deuxième vague de 10 à
12 semaines et donc ceci fait pour une
consommation de 40 millions de
de masques par semaine ça fait 400
millions si on prend dix semaines
il faut à 2 800 millions si on va la
deuxième vague voilà donc effectivement
s'il doit y avoir un stock fixe il doit
avoir cette dimension là et à
l'intérieur de ce stock comme vous
l'évoquez c'est pour ça que l'expérience
qui est menée en nouvelles aquitaine est
intéressante
une partie qui serait attribuée à la
population en période hivernale ou qui
seraient
ailleurs dans cette période là de telle
sorte que le stock soit ventilé au fur
et à mesure des années de péremption
puisque maintenant elle nous sommes nous
sont données je n'ai je n'ai pas
souvenir d'un échange entre la santé et
les producteurs pour nuancer cette date
de péremption
je pense était assez compliqué à pouvoir
réaliser mais de fait maintenant il faut
qu'on les prenne en compte
d'ailleurs vous le savez les normes
changent très régulièrement et donc il
est sans doute raisonnable de se donner
durée de vie limitée et d'utiliser les
produits par contre et je termine juste
part ça aujourd'hui favoriser une
production nationale qui vous le savez a
été ciblé jusqu en 2011 2012
à l'heure de l'europe des règles de
concurrence impose quand même une
réflexion d'état pour savoir si
effectivement ce stock est reconstituée
et comment il est ventilé sans faire de
concurrence à d'autres organisations qui
peuvent proposer des masques à la vente
et c'est donc là il ya un sujet je pense
pour l'avenir une petite gymnastique à
faire dans cette audition c'est qu'à
chaque fois qu'on finit par les fouette
un micro gina vrai parce que sinon
monsieur ciotti
non juste une toute petite précision sur
les 40 millions que vous évoquez donc
pour les pour l'hôpital par an en
période normale 40 millions par semaine
en période de crise ce sont des ffp2 ou
d'échangé et chirurgicaux à
ça ce sont des masques chirurgicaux
adultes en l'occurrence puisque les
pédiatriques sont quand même peu peut
utiliser entre 800 entre 800 millions et
1 milliard
merci non poursuivre alors monsieur
penchèrent françois bourdillon là nous
nous nous expliquait hier que
donc on a son arrivée il ya l'expertisé
effectivement sur les masques il y en a
600 millions qui sont inutilisables il
reste à peu près environ 150 environ 150
millions on voulait savoir pourquoi
on avait mis autant de temps pour
expertiser les masques on comprend qu'il
ya une nouvelle norme et qu'il faut se
tenir à cette nouvelle norme
bon ça y est compris qu'il y avait au
moins pas de 2,2 d'erreurs ou de faute
dans le la gestion oufa dans le le
contrôle en tout cas dans le contrôle
des masques qui étaient stockés dans de
bonnes conditions par contre à partir du
moment où d'un seul coup et d'un sol il
ya 600 millions de masques qui
disparaissent pourquoi on les recommande
pas quoi
cc c'est vraiment la question est à qui
ça combes c'est vraiment une question
très précise que je vous pose est ce que
c'est un combat national sans doute une
partie puisque ces stocks sont
centralisées ou aux régionales par les
ars
bon c est ce que oui ou non il ya une
faute de ne pas avoir recommandé c'est
de recommander ces masques peut-être que
oui peut-être que non parce que on dit
également qu'il ya des évolutions dont
la dans la sensibilité ou dans la
doctrine sur l'intérêt d'avoir un stock
important de masques vous semblez le
dire que c'est pas le cas il ya de toute
façon dont tous les cas un principe de
précaution
1 et 2 il ya aussi un deuxième principe
c'est que dans n'importe quelle
entreprise
on passe d'un système à un autre on
attend comme si deuxième système soit
complètement ayant mis en place pour
abandonner le premier là on a quand même
l'impression que vous envoyez des stocks
de masques dans les hôpitaux
sur le plan régional sans vérifier que
tout s'est mis en place dans de bonnes
conditions
et puis on découvre quand la crise
arrive des tensions partout où il ya eu
un problème
merci je vais laisser mes autres
collègues poser leurs questions parce
que comme on doit on procéder à une
autre audition tout de suite après comme
ça vous aurez le temps de préparer vos
réponses donc julien bost rozic
oui merci madame la présidente merci
monsieur valait parce que c'est vrai
vous avez apporté beaucoup de réponses
très précises mais du coup ça apporte
des questions d'autant plus simplement
je voulais c'est un peu en lien avec ce
que disait mon collègue lagarde c'est
vrai que finalement on se pose la
question de se dire les masques avant
2010 finalement n'avait plus vraiment de
légitimité et donc ça voudrait dire
qu'on aurait pu probable on essaie
peut-être ce qui s'est passé je voudrais
avoir des précisions expertise et
uniquement les masques de 2010 à 2014
avant la norme est juste à titre
indicatif est ce que vous avez une idée
du coup ça représentait cet audit par
sentex belle d'autre part moi je
voudrais revenir mais on l'a déjà
beaucoup dit mais je n'ai pas encore
tout compris dont vous nous dites la
gestion de la nouvelle doctrine la
gestion des équipements de protection je
vais aller un peu plus loin parce qu'on
a beaucoup parlé des masques on n'a pas
beaucoup parlé du reste par exemple les
sur luz qui ont été un vrai sujet la
gestion des équipements de protection
incombe aux employeurs donc ce sont les
ars si j'ai bien compris qu'ils doivent
s'en occuper
donc par quels moyens vérifie t-il et
quelle quelle personne qu'elle de
structure quelle organisation donne une
vision du stock qu'il faudrait est-ce
que c'est santé publique france est ce
que ce sont les ars et puis une vraie
question qui n'a pas encore été afin
madame la présidente vous n'avez l'avait
engagé
on n'a pas eu de réponse c'est sur la
ville parce que les professionnels de
ville qui les gérait qui leur proposait
qui leur donnait des objectifs en termes
d'équipements de protection est juste
une dernière chose vous le faire précisé
parce que c'est vrai que ça a été un
sujet de polémique en début de crise par
rapport à ces professionnels de ville on
a beaucoup entendu dire finalement on
nous ment on nous dit de ne pas prendre
de ffp2 parce qu'il n'y en a pas mais en
fait vous nous dites que les ffp2
n'avait une recommandation que pour des
métiers très spécifiques y compris au
sein des médecins donc on peut imaginer
l'ayant qu'en ville grosso modo aucun
médecin n'est concerné par le port de
ffp2 donc les masques chirurgicaux dans
la médecine de ville sont suffisants si
je comprends bien
merci merci martine vos nerfs
merci madame la présidente monsieur
valais merci pour votre présence ici est
peut-être sortir du champ des masques
pour revenir sur votre déplacement en
alsace les 19 et 20 mars où vous
rencontrez en effet les équipes de la rs
et les équipes hospitalières du chu de
strasbourg du centre hospitalier de
colmar et de mulhouse est ce que vous
aviez une feuille de route particulière
une feuille de mission pour ce
déplacement
si oui qui vous avez fait cette feuille
de mission et est ce que vous avez fait
une note particulière écrite et qui vous
l'avez vous remise si on peut peut-être
là la voir en bénéficier qu'est ce que
vous en avez pensé de cette situation
dans l'est de la france
à ce moment là et est ce que vous avez
pu également être en contact avec des
médecins libéraux notamment certains
médecins mulhousiens qui s'était déjà
exprimé dans la presse par par cris de
désespoir parce qu'ils avaient le
sentiment d'alerté
la rs et de ne pas être de ne pas être
entendus je vous remercie
merci sophie auconie merci monsieur
vallée pour toutes ces explications très
très pédagogique et très accessible deux
trois questions la première il y a dans
la fonction publique un certain nombre
d'hommes et de femmes extrêmement
experts extrêmement éduquer extrêmement
capé et je ne comprends pas comment plus
de 600 millions de masques ont dû être
détruits par des erreurs de stockage il
y à un certain nombre de principes le
diagramme de gantt par exemple sur le
first in first out c'est du pur
l'entreprise privée c'est élémentaire
parce que si une entreprise privée doit
détruire plus de 600 millions de ces
produits de ces matières premières a
bien c'est sa perte et que l'état que la
fonction publique participe à ce genre
de manquement me semble extrêmement
inquiétant et donc je voudrais savoir
comment est-ce qu'on peut harry
et dans la fonction publique entourés
d'experts comme c'est le cas autour de
nous nous pouvons arriver à ce genre
d'incongruités et le mot est faible
deuxième sujet pour vous est-ce que
l'organisation territoriale de la santé
et efficace vous savez que je les d'hier
mais notre rôle à nous législateurs
c'est légiférer appliquée contrôle et
corrigé est-ce que la mise en oeuvre par
exemple des agences régionales de santé
2010 sont aujourd'hui efficace
est ce qu'elles ont démontré à travers
cette crise majeure sanitaires elles
qu'elles ont démontré de leur efficacité
voire de l'efficience et surtout est-ce
que ça a été équitable à travers
l'ensemble du territoire
et là je parle de la métropole comme des
territoires ultramarins
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
valais je vous répète les paroles merci
madame la présidente j'ai peut-être
commencer par ces dernières questions
qui appellent à une expérience récente
de ma part et peut être tout de suite
sur les sur les agences régionales de
santé puisque en fait j'ai été dans le
grand est et j'ai rencontré les équipes
de la direction territoriale de
strasbourg j'ai eu aussi le directeur
général
en échange deux fois et puis après quand
je suis revenu aux côtés de marc martin
hirsch il m'avait demandé de le faire
aussi un travail de lien avec aurélien
rosso donc le directeur général de l'ars
est il de ile-de-france donc j'ai eu
l'expérience de deux agences régionales
dans cette période sur des temps courts
donc
je ne voudrais pas prétendre pouvoir
décrire l'entièreté des organisations et
de leurs et de leur réussite pendant la
crise qu vite cependant ici et là j'ai
vu des expériences très intéressante en
particulier donc dans la partie grand
test
les agents seraient les agences
régionales a su utiliser une
organisation territoriale qui sur le
papier parfois pas encore optimale qui
est le groupement hospitalier territoire
puisque en réalité il est de taille
variable de composition variable mais
dans le cas de la crise qu vide il ya eu
un usage de ce groupement hospitalier
territoire avec une entité qui a été
reconnu comme l'entité de coordination
et avec pour chacune de ses proches
chacun de ces groupes en hausse pitt et
territoires un référent de crise d'un
directeur médical de crise qui était
évidemment le plus souvent un est un
anesthésiste ou un réanimateur et qui
coordonnait finalement les forts pour
les différents établissements sur les
besoins en unités de lits de réanimation
sur les usages de deux ventilateurs
supplémentaires et aussi sur le
déplacement de ressources humaines
capables de venir renforcer les équipes
d'établissement en établissement et ceci
a été jusqu'à un partenariat public
privé qui s'est trouvée
engagé et avec une solidarité qui a été
très intéressante
donc j'ai vu dans ce cadre de la crise
l'utilisation d'une unité qui est
peut-être un peu administratives et pas
forcément toujours de partenariat si
fort que cela sur le plan médical se
renforcer de façon importante et je suis
certain que ce sont des éléments qui
perdureront après après la crise pour
par exemple d'écrire sur la rs
ile-de-france le sujet des
établissements d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes
et donc là la difficulté parfois de
leurs médicalisation de la la capacité
d'envoyer des soins ou faire le suivi de
avec des équipes d'hygiène ou avec
différents types de processus
d'accompagnement important pour la
gestion de crise ce qu'on a vu par
exemple ça a été une organisation qui
s'est faite en cohérence avec les
filière gériatrique de l'île de france
chacune des filières gériatrique
reprenant à son compte les ehpad avec
lesquels elle se constitue
elle se constituer sur une entité
territoriale est donc important tout le
soutien aussi bien en soi un médicaux qu
en soins infirmiers et en permanence de
nuit avec des filières qui ont été
présentes
du matin au soir et avec une permanence
de nuit qui existaient soit ce soit pour
la filière soit qu'on avait installé sur
le centre picpus pour l'ensemble de
l'île de france pour la nuit profonde et
les week-ends donc il ya il ya une
organisation qui est faite du pilotage
d'une autorité administrative de santé
et qui s'est fait ensuite
et là je n'étais pas sur le terrain mais
aussi avec les préfets et plutôt pour la
partie qui a été la partie de dépistage
d'identification des cas et de
sollicitations d'un syndrome de services
sociaux et complémentaires que les
préfets et les maires pouvaient avoir de
façon plus plus forte alors à leur
disposition donc on
je crois que la crise aura permis de
mieux comprendre l'usagé du système de
santé et aussi aura permis à beaucoup de
médecins de se renforcer sur l'idée de
la santé publique et de la prévention ce
qui est un mérite important de 2,7
cet épisode vous m'avez interrogé sur
le rationnel
d'élimination de produits dégradés
évidemment je ne peux pas rentrer dans
la période 2018-2019 où je n'étais pas
présent
et le first in first out à la logique
c'est à dire comme je le disais tout à
l'heure le stock central de vitry un de
ses objectifs c'était pouvoir faire un
inventaire récurrent de d'enlever les
produits dégradés et de faire une
analyse qui soit une analyse
d'échantillonnage rationnelle sur les
produits présents je disais tout à
l'heure c'était à la fois une plate
forme d'équipement mais c'était aussi un
établissement pharmaceutique où les
questions de péremption de produits
étaient récurrentes et où le pharmacien
responsable et le pharmacien adjoint qui
était présent faisait le faisait le
travail l'expertisé de son ex-belle le
coût estimé j'ai pas précisément le
devis mais c'était de l'ordre de 600
mille euros donc c'est quand même une
note qu on sait qu'une facture
conséquente c'est pour ça qu'elle
demandait qu'on soit dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour que
l'échantillonnage qui allait être fait
reçoit soit cohérent par rapport à ce
qui était attendu
voilà pour pour une partie des questions
et vous m'avez aussi interroger donc sûr
le lien qui peut y avoir entre les
médecins libéraux à mulhouse je n'ai pas
eu des échanges avec les médecins
libéraux puisque en fait ma mission m'a
demandé ce qui était de ma lettre de
mission donc ma mission était de pour le
compte de l'assistance publique des
hôpitaux de paris donc pour matt martin
hirsch auquel j'avais offert la
possibilité de travailler
il m'avait demandé d'aller voir sur
place puisque la la vague était en
avance malheureusement sur le grand est
et qu'elle n'avait pas débuté sur l'île
de france pas de manière franche
il m'avait demandé de regarder les
adaptations de mulhouse et colmar pour
amener un certain nombre d'hypothèses de
travail et d'amélioration de la
préparation toujours l'idée de la
préparation du système de santé et donc
ma mission se borner à cela j'ai eu des
échanges avec un seul médecin
généraliste de strasbourg
braud qui m'a fait remonter
effectivement les besoins qui pouvait
avoir en équipements mé mais pas
d'éléments très très très substantielle
et donc pour répondre à ces à cette
attribution des équipements encore une
fois le le dispositif horse and qui
rentrait dans la loi en 2016 prévoit que
les agences fasse travailler ensemble
les professionnels de santé y compris
les u r ps donc les unions régionales de
procès le santé pour préparer les
situations sanitaires exceptionnelles et
donc ils ont des réunions et ils doivent
se préparer ensemble pour permettre
d'affronter ces situations de crise
la logique et ramifié encore une fois un
système de santé fonctionne avec les
personnes au plus près du terrain
ceux qui sont à la fois les sentinelles
mais qui sont aussi les acteurs d'un
système de santé totalement efficace
voilà des voilà quelques quelques
éléments de réponse j'ai fait un court
rapport que je pourrais vous donner mal
à la présidente qui que j'ai remis à
d'abord à martin hirsch que j'avais
selon une procédure processus
contradictoire que j'avais d'abord
adressé aux équipes de mulhouse de
colmar et de strasbourg pour leur
demander leur retour et non amendé et
ensuite une fois que ces amendements
étaient faits gelée adressé à martin
hirsch qui l'a envoyé à aurélien
rousseau et on m'avait demandé de
pouvoir le donner au directeur général
de la santé au direct la directrice
générale de l'offre de soins
ce que j'ai fait
et il a été transmis aussi à la
conseillère santé de monsieur macro je
pense qu'il a dû aller aussi à matignon
voilà merci je voudrais revenir sur la
question des masques bon on a évoqué ce
stock d'un milliard je m'en avait parlé
tout à l'heure vous l'avez révoqué je
crois qu'on a mesurée que vous attachiez
importance à la présence de ce stock
stratégique pour qu'on comprenne bien
vous aviez comme opérateur l'eprus qui
se transforme en santé publique france
dans la convention qui lie je pense la
dgs ou avec l'eprus il est il est
indiqué jean pierre door qui est notre
collègue est pas là aujourd'hui mais a
été un des fondateurs de près son
rapport de l'eprus que chaque année il
devait y avoir un renouvellement ces
mêmes c'est inscrit dans la convention
des stocks stratégiques et des stocks de
masques
vous nous dites que vous avez fait une
commande de 100 millions de masques
alors je sais pas si elle est si la
saisine de l'eprus
et fait avant votre arrivée ou après
mais je pense que la commande doit
arriver en 2014
en tout cas donc si vous pouvez me
préciser sur cette date
et est ce qu'il y a eu d'autres
commandes et de ce fait pourquoi on
s'est progressivement éloigné de cet
objectif que vous rappeliez vous même et
qui me paraît très pertinent d'un stock
d'un milliard de masques
merci monsieur le rapporteur
effectivement le contrat d'objectifs et
de performance prévoit un programme
triennal d'achat et qui concerne
d'ailleurs les masses mais beaucoup
d'autres produits qui concerne ses
stocks stratégiques et la commande qui
avait été initié en juillet 2013 donc de
200 millions de masques et qui viendra
en réalité dans les stocks pour les
années qui suivront selon à une
incrémentation progressive
en réalité 56 millions en 2014
39 millions en 2015 et et 1 5 million
complémentaires en 2016 plus les deux
fois 20 millions qui viendront pour les
stocks pédiatrique
en réalité ce qui avait été envisagé
pour ce triennal c'était de remonter de
100 millions de masques par an et donc
c'était l'objectif qu'on s'était
assignée afin d'une part de revenir à au
plus près possible de la cible du
milliard mais aussi pour rentrer
peut-être dans cette logique de lissage
que qui prévalent qui allait prévaloir
de plus en plus eu égard à la question
d'une péremption qui finalement donné
croissante des normes qui évolue et
c'est en fait la période que j'ai vécu
et donc j'ai rappelé un sa tombe
d'épisodes situation sanitaire
exceptionnel ebola en 2014 3,4 millions
d'euros de mobilisation de la réserve et
d'achats de matériels 100 millions de
masses et 3,2 millions d'euros
les attentats terroristes de 2015
l'accroissement des stocks de
respirateurs portable l'achat des stocks
de tamiflu pour les hivers que j'ai
indiqué à chaque fois des sommes qui
décret monte
d'autant les possibilités d'achat la
même année aux 10 k 1.5 millions d'euros
pour l'année 2016 notamment
et puis d'autres éléments donc le stock
rénové de vaccin antivariolique qui lui
aussi ancien on avait des produits qui
remontait à des années reculer et qui
qui méritait effectivement une
restauration
je pense retrouver peut-être je
regarderai après donc des produits qui
remontait à vraiment tout début de la
vaccination de la variole et donc il
méritait d'être rénové et puis aussi le
contexte post attentats là que la
crainte d'une attaque qu'ils soient de
niveau nucléaire ou chimique qui ont
amené à renforcer les psn dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure sur la dynamique
des antidotes et des protections des
équipements de protection nrbc et un
centre d'outils que qu'on a acheté dans
ce contexte d'attentats comme des
ventilateurs j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure
qu'on a d'ailleurs utilisés et en
pratique dans ce contexte
de risques nrbc et donc de dévolution de
des pros des protections les dépenses
qui sont usuellement dans cette gamme de
références sont de l'ordre de 15% passe
à 25% et le contrat générale
interministérielle de l'époque le cgi
n'a pas apporté des moyens
supplémentaires dans dans la situation
que nous connaissions
les financements de l'eprus ont comme
d'autres agences monsieur bourdillon
parlé hier subi un certain nombre
d'évolutions mais il faut savoir aussi
que beaucoup de ces opérateurs avaient
des fonds de roulement conséquent et que
ça c'est pas parce que la charge pour
subvention de service public diminue
avec pour autant les moyens de
l'opérateur disparaissait ou diminuer
dans proportions une compensation c'est
fait pour un centre de ses agences en
amélioration de l'efficacité et de
l'efficience budgétaire en utilisation
du fonds de roulement
pour autant je crois quand on est on
était dans une sécurité de centaines de
millions de masques et d'un stock qui
avait été recentraliser pour une somme
conséquente le la réinstallation de
vitry se compter en plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'euros
donc il y avait eu un effort qui avait
été réalisé une sécurisation de ces
stocks est en pratique d'autres
situation de sanitaires exceptionnel qui
se sont enchaînés pendant toutes ces
années là qui nous ont amenés à faire
des choix qui n'ont pas des choix qui
n'ont pas totalement amoindri c'est
qu'on a on a chaque année faire entrer
des dizaines de millions de masques pour
continuer de renforcer ce stock et
pendant cette période il a
indiscutablement augmenté offert heures
de ma part il n'y a pas eu d'autres
commandes sous votre direction que celle
qui intervient avant votre arrivée en
juillet 2013 vous avez raison monsieur
le rapporteur la commande et est
sollicité par jean yves grall donc mon
prédécesseur en juillet vous avez
parfaitement raison et elle s'étale dans
les périodes où je suis présent pendant
trois ans et je m'assure simplement
qu'une partie de ces masses peuvent
peuvent être achetés parce que la
commande par mais l'engagement après
doit être honorée de voilà c'est
l'épreuve qui le fait exactement mais
elle le fait aussi dans cette
négociation par rapport à d'autres
mesures qu'elle est obligée de prendre
et puis après on respecte le temime la
présidente je vois que vous y êtes
sensibles oui c'est pas pratique dans
cette salle qui a bon vous évoquez les
contraintes budgétaires il est le
contexte notamment terroristes qui
impose de nouvelles dispositions et pose
de nouvelles menaces qui a procédé à ses
arbitrages budgétaires à quel niveau
au niveau de la dgse au niveau
ministériel au niveau interministériel
au niveau de matignon
donc c'est une discussion qui se fait
entre la direction et l'opérateur dans
le dialogue de gestion et donc avec des
choix des arbitrages qui se font par
rapport à ce qui est peut être engagée
les choix qui se font à l'égard de
situations sanitaires supplémentaires et
comment finalement l'objectif essentiel
est retenu est satisfait donc cesser
c'est au niveau de ma direction de mes
services et de la direction de l'eprus
puis de santé publique france dans un
dialogue de gestion que ces éléments là
se feront le dialogue avec les
opérateurs est un est un point très
important de la tutelle on n'a pas
aujourd'hui parler de la tutelle des
opérateurs c'est un sujet important et
c'est pour lui c'est la raison pour
laquelle on l'avait renforcé la demande
et la même toile qu'on puisse renforcer
l'animation du système d' agences le
travail collaboratif des opérateurs
entre eux mais aussi pour moi de façon
plus prosaïque dans la conduite des
travaux avec les agences j'avais
introduit l'obligation d'une réunion
mensuelle pour permettre d'aborder les
différents sujets qu'une qu'un opérateur
peut avoir vis-à-vis de sa tutelle donc
dans une compréhension de l'importance
de la de l'indépendance de l'expertisé
en même temps de la capacité à agir et à
mettre en place des dispositions de
réponse qui soit cohérente avec les
objectifs portés par le ministère et
donc il nous a semblé dans cette période
là que nous ne restions cohérent avec la
cible principale qui était la nôtre et
que nous faisions face en même temps à
des situations sanitaires qui s'imposait
à nous de manière plus brutale
voilà vous venez d'entendre benoît
valais il a confirmé qu'aucune commande
de masques de grande ampleur n'avait été
effectué alors qu'il était lui-même à la
tête de la direction générale de la
santé
cette audition comme toutes celles de la
commission denquête est à retrouver sur
notre site
lcp point fr